Jane Brown is taking the country music
world by storm his song homesick is now
his fifth number-one hit on Billboard's
Country airplay charts he also just
released a new duet with John Legend
this one's called
last time I say sorry Sunday night the
two will perform the song together for
the first time and they will do it from
their own homes during ACM presents our
country here is a preview
[Music]
I said it cuz I made it but you still
wouldn't let it go so I swallow my pride
see from your side
[Music]
I'm sorry cane Brown joins us now from
his home in Nashville cane Brown all I
have to say to you is baby come back to
me give me one more chance one more
chance to be be a better man I love you
do you recognize that song do you
recognize me even though I think it's
very bad you know you and I were
supposed to be together I was coming out
in March to do a profile with you to
promote this and then coronavirus split
us apart but I'm so delighted that
you're here and I can't wait to meet you
in person but one of the highlights of
our country is to do it with you and
John Legend I got such a kick out of
watching the two of you together and
then I heard that you two wrote that
song together in less than a day how did
you all do that yes a man a man John
wrote that and about an hour and a half
it came pretty naturally you know we
just started to start talking about both
of our relationships and I'm usually
mainly the guys in a relationship
they'll say sorry for something they did
and then they'll turn around and they'll
do it again and me and John both like
that's the worst feeling in the world so
they kind of just really came to
actually you know it's funny because
John has talked about it too and said
that before the song he had had a fight
with Chrissy we all know Chrissy Teigen
very well and then you came and said you
know I just had a fight disagreement
with Kaitlyn too so this song kind of
resonated with you with both of you and
you say it's actually a love song how so
I actually get that but you explained
how it's actually a love song yeah I
think it's a love song because it's I
base it on my on my end I wrote it for
my wife just saying that you know I
never want to mess up you know I just
want to love you you know for the rest
of my life and never have to tell you
sorry again so
anytime we ever fight you know I cut we
kind of just played that song and
listened to it and you know it just
calms both of us down
I think Kaitlyn's a lucky girl but I'm
so fascinated by you cane Browne because
listen Amazon has a great documentary
about you about selling out at the
Staples Center and you really take us
behind the scenes because you're one of
the few country artists I think it's ten
you might be number 11 who's sold out at
the Staples Center in Los Angeles on
your own on stage and to see that crowd
cheering for you and singing your songs
take me to that moment what that means
and what that meant to you
it meant the world to me it didn't
really hit me until I walked on stage
and then I remember like some took over
and it was kind of I remember saying it
we sold out the Staples Center it would
but it was amazing for us because it was
our we had to cancel that show because
we our drummer passed away so it was our
first show playing again after that
tragedy so for us it was amazing we all
before did a toast and said this is for
Kenny and I really felt like it was that
he was there so I think that was the
most exciting part not only is a Staples
Center iconic but those other tent
country artists are you know Carrie
Underwood Garth Brooks Shania Twain the
legend so it was just it's amazing to be
a part of that community Kane I just
love your speaking voice I love your
singing voice too I'm not the only one
Anthony you have anything for Kane yeah
I want to jump in Kane we know the the
ACM Awards have been postponed but we're
gonna get this this great concert on
Sunday night with with all of you
performing at home what does it mean to
you to be part of something like that
I think it's I think it just shows how
much of a community country music is and
how much they love their fans and
they're willing to get the fans of music
and and this weird time I feel like
music uplifts everybody so I'm glad
we're going to do this you know people
are going to be talking I won't be
telling my kids or my daughter this I
was born in the blizzard in 1993 I'm
gonna say that you were born during
Corona at home so it's gonna it's gonna
be amazing that you know I get to be a
part of something so special I'm so glad
they see and they're doing this and it's
gonna be something that's talked about
you know down and down the line in the
future you mentioned little Kingsley
cane people say that she has changed
your life you have a twinkle in your eye
your wife's name is Kaitlyn your name is
Kane Kenzi starts with a K I guess to be
part of the Kane Brown family your name
has to start with a K I like it King
starts with the cages throwing that out
there for the next baby but this is
something this is something I saw in the
Amazon special from somebody on your
crew which I thought which really got to
me he said for Kane Brown this is a
pinnacle where he's come from but a
start to where he's going
I made the hair stand up on my neck for
you where are you going where would you
like to go Kane Brown I don't know I
don't set goals but I always you know
just trying to be further than it was
yesterday
you know it's my mentality so you know
hopefully the sky's the limit where my
new album we're working on I have a lot
of features that people probably
wouldn't it's just expect me doing so
I'm just excited to see where we go you
know there's no boundaries where I'm at
I don't like to be put in the box I just
like to you know do whatever I want to
do so my fans are behind me and I'm just
excited to see the future goes I agree
Kane you are not in a box there's nobody
like you out there I'm so excited for
your music I have all your stuff I like
I'm a big big fan thank you for joining
us I really appreciate it
you can watch ACM presents our country
this Sunday you're welcome
this Sunday night at 8:00 7:00 central
right here on CBS